and yesterday I
didn't posted a video what I was talking
to Maddie yassan yeah and man son what a
sweetheart he is he responded can you
pull up the Tweet with him he's such a
sweet guy on the level of like uh
there's a sweetheart there's certain
words I would say when I think about a
guy yeah this like they you know
wholesome yeah go up a little bit keep
going up it's somewhere in a reaction if
you just keep going up uh no you were
good yeah keep going up keep going up
keep going up
no no he resp he retweeted and he
responded to it and I want to uh Rob to
show the guy tweets like you know he's
tweeted 160 000 times 150 000 times it's
a lot of times he's written like 17
Bibles is what he's written just based
on his tweets okay right there zoom in
right there on his response and I have
no idea who you are but since you're
asking and assuming go actually read the
book especially the chapter on Gish
Galloping and then come back to me all
may become clear to you Maddie I am
enamored by your Fame and uh I'm I'm so
amazed by how amazing and a famous
person you are and more power to you
keep kicking ass with what you got going
on there but the point is when you're
talking about all these things that
we're doing here with the uh with the
business right when you're going through
a certain Market
these guys are still defending Peter
Hotes every day Peter Hotes is tweeting
20 times sharing articles of people
saying why he shouldn't debate RFK
so what do you think when somebody ever
if you go to Peter hotel's Twitter
profile just go to his Twitter profile
we've been talking about the sky lot
because by the way Peter I hope you say
thanks to Joe Rogan because we're going
to show the influence of Joe Rogan check
this out look how many followers he's
got how many followers does he have on
Twitter what's the number 455 write that
down can you write it down so we can
remember
455.1 455.1 okay here we go zoom in a
little bit so we can see all the tweets
skip that one because that one he's
selling covet keep going
uh so keep so he's keep going every one
of these tweets is about why he
shouldn't debate anybody keep going keep
going keep going keep going keep going
keep going keep going keep going he's
Joe Rogan's wants a scientist to debate
a vaccine denier turning him down was
the right thing to do Vox next one you
know thank you for Peter Ortez for
sharing the new piece from Time Magazine
RFK is a pedaling and extraordinary
amount of disinformation about vaccines
on a daily basis so what's the article
Peter retweets RFK is dead wrong about
vaccines Time Magazine right all right
so all right pillar of knowledge there
yeah so so now go to socialblade Rob if
you can do that go to socialblade go to
socialblade.com and then go to the top
right where it says YouTube change it to
Twitter
there you go and type in Peter Hotes his
name okay this is called the power of
Joe Rogan
no no you got to put them together you
got to put them together yeah just put
just put the name together there you go
like that perfect so now watch this look
at this go down look how many followers
he was getting go lower slowly go lower
lower lower
because that's all he's not letting you
keep going Lord right there he was not
getting any followers all of a sudden
Joe Rogan's made him famous wow a little
bit zoom in yeah Peter hotels was not a
household name
400 38 000 55
000 13
000 3900 it's called The Power of Joe
Rogan something all of these mainstream
media people hate that of Joe Rogan has
this kind of influence where he says one
thing and the Army shows up who is this
guy yeah and by the way he helps you
find your audience because the people
that don't like Joe Rogan say oh my God
another person that doesn't like Joe let
me go follow him hey Dr Peter Hotes I'm
your number one fan so Dr Hotes next
time you're in Austin uh I don't know if
Joe has time but if you do if you're in
Austin maybe go to his Comedy Club have
a laugh or two on the comedians he has
there but uh what a sweetheart I think
he's sending a Joe Rogan a Christmas
card Christmas after all
yeah yeah but again you're you're
sitting here wondering who seems like
the one that has Courage the one that is
questioning Authority and the other one
that is defending Authority folks if
you're listening to this you're part of
one of two camps you're questioning
Authority that's forcing people to do
certain things they didn't want to do or
you're you know defending Authority and
you're not listen I'm not telling you
anything about Law and Order of course
there's something called Law and Order
but some people that Force certain
things down people's throat maybe we
ought to question them to see if that
was right and it's not like Pat like
questioning the authority like the
authority hasn't been screwing us
forever you got to be on the on the
other side not to surprise me when
something like this happens if you have
the facts look at history if you have
the facts you're running to the
microphone to debate and you're Fearless
about it when people have the facts
there after that microphone and they
want to be heard when you don't have the
facts you have all you get all your
people to say oh tell them all the
reasons why you shouldn't do it tell
them all the reasons why you shouldn't
do it you know what it reminds me of Pat
it reminds me of a certain letter in
Washington that had 50 signatures on it
that said nothing to see here from the
in quote intelligence community and Joe
Biden it's like no no we don't want to
talk about it we just want to look to a
letter that says 50 people saying uh
nothing to see here and I'll sign this
letter that's what A tes is doing right
now he is out there a coward doctor you
are a coward and you are having all of
your friends just basically Embrace
promote and project your cowardice you
refuse to go out and you've got proxies
out there saying oh don't do it to give
yourself the line and the opening not to
do it if you had the fact sir and you
could stand up to the heat of debate sir
you would be in the arena you sir are a
coward Vinnie tell people out there what
it means when someone shouts nothing to
see here yeah like when you and I'm
pretty sure everybody in the audience
has when you when you go up to like it's
like something has happened and there's
cop cars maybe there's a fire somebody
was killed and whenever a cop goes hey
move along there's nothing to see here
you know what that means it was a mob
hit
yeah there's definitely something to see
there I like Tom I agree it's like you
are the professional and you have people
that aren't a professional in your field
an expert what are you so scared of it's
the truth bro and notice all those fact
Checkers Tom we didn't have fact
Checkers until the truth really started
coming out now you have to check check
our fact get out of here bro they're all
they're all full of crap no honestly
here nothing to see here Tom that was a
that was an interesting response you had
there for uh our friends so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
thank you
foreign